welcome to Verbier Switzerland one of
Europe's most exclusive ski resorts
we're here to show you why and just how
expensive it can be if money is an issue
in 2014 a permitting ban on building
second homes will make chalets like this
one listed at 25 million Swiss francs
that's nearly 28 million US dollars even
more exorbitant with six bedrooms a pool
and a sauna its grandfathered in under
the old law so a potential buyer doesn't
have to be a full-time resident to
purchase it the swiss regulation caps a
town's holiday properties at 20% we have
at the moment more than 85% of second
homes in verb you already and so what it
means is what's already built and what's
going to be built in the next two years
it's going to become a lot more valuable
I would think that you know say a 10%
increase within the next couple of years
is certainly not to be ruled out so new
construction is frozen but demand is
heating up already in a market that
towers above its Alpine neighbors buyers
and sellers were waiting for clarity on
the law now sellers know they have the
upper hand when you hook yourself I just
really matter you know when we get the
right price basically I think 25 million
is a bargain for this chalet
we have lovely old oak beams and pine we
have the floors which are 400 years old
we have french-born stone floors so all
of these things are so beautiful in the
valleys of Switzerland the floor for ski
property is as high is the tree line but
there's one loophole for the thrifty ski
bum move to a resort village full-time
haunts nickles Bloomberg Verbier